This is the carol N.E.H. American English dialect recordings
collection produced with funding from the National Endowment for the Humanities and the
Center for Applied Linguistics. Tape number one side a.
We
must talk now about what we are going to do.
And plan
accordingly. And I want to express my
thanks to Judge Samuel see
Barry who has given so much to this
city who has made clean government possible in
this that they always started before
thirty four remember my campaign of nineteen twenty
nine when I've told the city about rotten conditions that existed here.
Remember when I was nominated by the Republican Party in twenty
nine and
grabbed the next day. I was a hard day. Remember that way that
was Dr
Reid but it was useful wasn't that. The charges that
are made was so startling that. Said hardly be
so and Judge Seabury proved beyond any reasonable doubt
of all the charges of I may want to I want to thank God.
I also want to thank a group of
friends who got together.
And petitions as it were for my nomination. I know
you meant
well and I know you were interested only in good government and
I want to thank each and every one of you for your
confidence and for your coverage. And for your own
selfish
interest in ours that.
But of course that isn't my technique when I want
a nomination. I submitted to the people and not
to political
bosses but it did bring
out the fact that we must elect a mare this year.
And I want to make very clear that I appreciate very kind of that.
I will not anti the Republican primaries.
I am not a candidate. For the Republican
nomination for mayor.
Now there are other groups.
And I want to make that clear again that
the decision must be left to the
people I want to ask my buddy good friends of the American
Labor Party not to nominate me and not
to put my name on there but NATION.
I am not going to run for mayor this year I
had many reasons. And I will give them to
you but you know.
It's been so amusing and to observe
the
panorama in the last few months this
panorama of
politicians this panorama of scheming and
conniving to do want to join forces to the
strong I a going to win this race.
Of course it's always difficult for the gentry of that kind. To get together
at every KSAN and cause. Belo and
Adonis the rest of the
racketeers perhaps have not yet
agreed on having a bank and
you have you know seen all this maneuvering. Yes and some very high officials.
Holding certain offices that are not supposed to be in politics have
been brain trusting some of this convince and
conspiracy to the story good government.
Because I knew all along my friends this decision was made
yesterday or today this decision was made back in nineteen
forty
one and so
that. I've been carrying on with the
full knowledge of what I was going to do knowing that the job was completed.
And that now. It was up to the people of this city to
decide whether they want to keep clean diesel government put clean law abiding
people in our city for the children of our
city whether they want to return to the
political reflect. That the in home which is losing the
racketeers in the tin box that's for the people to decide.
And I must be decided on that issue alone and for instance at the other
evening at the national Republican Club there was quite a debate on the subject and there
you have a level of intelligence somewhat higher than the discrete
clubs and what was the discussion that well look why do you support the governor
next year and we support him this year how do we know that we would
support the government next year you
have Howard general. I don't
know and I would make any such dirty deal.
I don't know who I'll support next year it all depends on the issues and the
candidates
but when I want to point out. Is that the selection of
a candidate for the mass should be only on fitness. And
not on any political Expedia I'm sorry.
Now but there are many reasons why I think.
I shouldn't run.
First there is always the danger of.
One becoming sort of stale in office. When I don't want to be become
stale at any
time I don't want to become indifferent. I don't want
to become so callous that I couldn't get indignant.
Yes and impatient didn't lose my temper when I hear a graph on corruption.
When I hear of crime and recognizing Oh I don't want.
I'd want to go all that way and then there's also a tendency.
That administration may become satisfied. It becomes sort of us. No
getting satisfied that we're doing so well.
Oh no no no no no no that's not good I want to keep on my toes all the time I want my
government to keep on its time was all the time I committed to be on their
toes and their. Change is
good and then another thing you know if an individual in in an executive office
too long he may become bossy and they tell me
I'm sort of inclined that way at parent. So that's something
else I miss look at.
But now here is something that I think is important I do not believe that
in our form of government. A key chief executive has
should be real acted time after
time the government of the city of New York is so large
that it cannot be compared with smaller
municipalities our. So the government is larger and greater and more
involved than that of any state in the union including our
own and so while it may be good in a small community for
one to stay on the job as mayor. I don't think it's whom some in
the city on a government as big as ours rotation in office.
Is good and is
wholesome it is necessary. In a
democracy it does not mean that because we have a rotation.
It must necessarily go from bad from good or bad or from bad to worse.
If that were true it would indeed be a sad commentary on our
democracy and in these times there's a tendency
to rally around and individual.
It is our democratic system that is important today
not individuals in a democracy can not be up
to retained and improved so
proper rotation in
office then something is wrong with the system and
I refuse to believe that there is anything wrong with our democratic
system when I can almost hear you
say there goes one idea again using
consistent even to support the president for a war.
Yes I
did and under the same circumstances I would do
it again under different circumstances I would
not have done it. It did not require a great student of
history on an expert on European politics in one nine hundred
forty to
know that our country would be involved in
war. Did not require much of a military genius to
know our complete and utter lack of
this
offense and of military preparation in nineteen forty.
I knew that even our own coaches out here. Was
not properly protected and we had no means of
protecting in those
days it would not be long before the real conditions that existed nine
hundred forty and the frantic preparations and the building up of our the fence of our
coast and mainland will become
history. I had some little part in the preparation of
that as a member of the permanent join boy. On the
fence with Canada.
No one in our entire country had the knowledge of European
Affairs and the grasp of the situation at that President Roosevelt.
I did not like the third term.
I don't think the person themselves like the third or I supported
him because under those conditions and the danger that we were facing at
the time I consider that the best interest of our country that the
president should remain in our place
in one thousand and forty four no other
decision could be made there was no choice.
And of course the American people
responded a great many of my very good friends who
are really interested in clean and none political government worked hard
to drive out the forces of
corruption from city
hall and were responsible for my
election back in nineteen thirty four they were
hurt and disappointed that I did support the president in
ninety four. I did it with my eyes open.
I knew that I was hurting my
friends and that they were disappointed. I was sorry and told them at the time
I did what I believed was the best interest of
our country. Now.
Of course.
As these machines are created. They have
terrible power. My friends if in nineteen thirty four when
I came here I would just to play along with
a political
party it would not have been difficult to build up a powerful machine
this thing or I could have built up a personal
political machine. What I could not have given you the kind of government.
That you had for twelve years and that I know you wanted.
The city would not be as it is
today. And I would not have
been myself. I know politics
well and you know that I know and could
have built up quite a powerful political machine. Others have done it.
And some are doing at him then
state today. I was
interested in the future of my city. I was
not interested in my own political future.
I did not
hesitate look around your study
now where are the politicians in office
and Valentine and Walsh control any
vote Ontario sanitation Stebbins of health
Berninger Aspinall are they county chairman not this great leaders. Mackenzie
of Marine more. Sublicense Wilson's housing. Do they represent any
political party. Wilkinson or soundman or
Patterson. Can they swing and
nominations on
all but they know their
jobs lie their approaches you hear public words Murdoch of standard
appeals are they political wire pullers and fixers of the old days.
Bob Moses the builder it tried it once it couldn't get many votes from itself
but he's a great
commissioner these men just know their jobs and this is the big play
my friends. There is no fixing there is no graft. There is no favoritism. There is
no
stealing that is the big difference between a number
political number partisan signed to the government and the own kind
that you throw out of office back in one thousand nine hundred thirty four.
Now
there are some personal reasons. I'll be sixty three
in
December I still have I hope.
Some years of useful service left
and I've had the
opportunity during the past forty years that I've been in public
service of acquiring some
experience and some training and I've worked very hard.
I've had hardly
know they cation or read since I've been in office he has mapped twelve
years is still spent one thing after the
other.